i'm gonna go down to the ground floor
and look for the police lights
apparently
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back
to at dead of night i need to go get my
radio i know and also i'm sorry it's
been so long
uh since the last episode if you hadn't
heard i broke my
foot uh and it's had some weird
side effects so uh i haven't been doing
a hundred percent but i'm gonna get back
into this because
it has been way too long so expect a lot
of episodes coming at you very quickly
about this game because i don't want to
let it get
uh forgotten as i've got more videos
that i need to do and other projects
that i need to work on and other stuff
that i need to get going and also
i need to watch out for jimmy okay i
don't even know what floor i'm on
okay so i need to go to the first floor
wait what floor am i on
no i'm on the first floor okay so this
is good i need to get to the first floor
story room
so i can get my radio and so i can get
back to doing what i need to do
everything's good so far so good
okay i don't know why he consistently
leaves it in here
it's kind of stupid of him but then
again he doesn't seem like the smartest
dude
all right got that now
i need to let me look at this one more
time g
okay so i need to go to the ground floor
okay so gn3 let's go to g
first let's go to g first just because
that's a good place to start g
means good good is what i'm doing
jimmy's not here
so it should be fun i'm gonna take the
staircase just because it's easier
and i think i'm not 100 sure about this
but i think it's less
incident of jimminess so if i can
withdraw on the jimminess
and i don't have to worry about jim
jiminy then i think i'm going to be
generally a little bit better
okay so do i gotta go back to the
kitchen
i heard something over there hello
what is that
what's the slim slamming
oh no oh no
okay that's those are new noises
those are new noises i know new noises
and those are new noises
hello why are you doing that
was something behind me i would never
use force like that on a patient mrs
hall
it goes against everything i believe it
you
have to understand he's making it all up
is he though is he though the answer is
yes absolutely he is
but is he though okay dr bozey
explaining about the whole problem oh
yeah is it doctor bose doctor bose
yes i'm comfortable uh-huh so what about
you and this whole
story about you not beating on jimmy
i saw you trying to interest what
happened with jimmy you seem desperate
[Music]
well that's good that seems like
progress well
story done no one did nothing and
everything is a-okay number two
okay so something about a uh
something about a key card huh of uh
number two huh all right if you say so
key card number two before i go on
number two i'm gonna just look
at what keys i have for number two so i
know what door i'm gonna be able to go
where's my keys
where's my keys where's my keys
where's my did he take all of my keys
did he take all of my keys
did he take my keys
my steez and my keys did he take my keys
oh my god do i not have keys
please tell me that's just like a
different context would show up my keys
but for some reason my keys aren't here
it's probably just that
it's probably just that that's probably
all it is
that's probably the entirety of the
problem that i have in front of my face
it's probably it that's probably it
that's probably
it probably okay
jamie you up here
okay i'm not here all right
my compass is telling me that something
is dissing way
oh
[Music]
ah
hate this room this room is
horrible oh no
look at you okay i have a i don't like
mannequins
i don't i don't like mannequins very
much at all i don't think they're good
um for anything or anyone unlock the
door first well that would be great if i
actually had
like keys but it really seems like i
don't have keys
which is very bizarre so i can't um
i can't unlock it because i don't have
keys was there a place that said
i have key have had keys because
i uh i don't have keys
there must be some way that i uh i can't
remember
the last time that i got killed
[Music]
i can't remember the last time that i
got killed
i i swear that it i didn't have to go
get my keys but
i might be wrong all right what if we're
we're just gonna have to make do without
i
i'm pretty sure that i can loop around
here to get to wherever this compass is
pointing
maybe i don't hear jimmy yet so i'm
assuming that we're okay
is that new i don't remember
i don't exactly remember there being
just a butt load of uh is it this one no
yeah i really don't remember there just
being a butt load
i have keys well where are they okay
i have keys apparently but whatever you
know it's fine
hello no okay so there's someone in here
when i turn around no
when i hide in the closet
when i hop out of the closet when i look
in the
eyehole when i return from the eye hole
no god damn it you can't get away from
me that easily jimmy
i think we should start again don't you
why don't you do what i asked you to do
this time that would be a good start
wouldn't it
oh maybe dr bose ain't as uh nice as dr
bose claims that dr bose b um
interesting that is a little bit strange
i'm going to go ahead and suggest that
that is strange is it dr boze
dr bosu there i have a question
yeah dr bose why were you uh
threateningly wrapping the
lanyard around your fingers
[Music]
why were you doing that what were you
doing what were you doing
i thought when he realized
[Music]
the worst you say okay the worst explain
how okay um
so the lie
you say the lie the lie okay the lie
the worst did it have something to do
with this scrapbook
you said jimmy made up another lie about
you a much worse lie
does that have something to do with what
you said about the scrapbook
[Applause]
jimmy accused me of the worst crime
possible
listen i don't know if the dead tell
lies
what am i looking at over there
was that the front door i think those
police lights at the front door
okay all right dr bose little concerning
about that
very actually concerning uh some might
say some might say
excessively concerning but i'm gonna go
down to the ground floor and look for
the police lights
apparently oh my
god the hell jimmy the hell
[Music]
[Applause]
you were yeah goddamn freaking
precious ass press my ass you
god damn sassafras oh hi
yeah okay where are you taking me was
this like a scripted thing skip
wake what do you mean skip wake i don't
even know what happened
how many times you gonna hit me in my
head one force trauma's
bad for people
[Music]
okay all right fine i got i don't have
my ghosty
suckinator i can't suckin ate the ghost
juice out of the universe i didn't
hear him did anyone else hear him
why was he right there the bastard
okay so i'm back on oh my god
oh my god oh my god
can he get me twice no
oh my god
oh my god dead end oh god damn it
what happens if you give me twice why
did he put me on the third floor of the
bastard
oh oh dead end i'm an idiot
god i'm an idiot stop running around or
i'm gonna run around on you
don't do it don't do it don't do it
oh who's banging oh wait is that
not bangy boo that's a ghost okay i
can't
do that right now i gotta go get my
radio i gotta get my radio
i'll be back later shut up also
also shut up
stressful it's stressful it's
surprisingly stressful
so i need to go to the first floor to
look at the
front door get another ghost scare
another spook okay i'm
just gonna take the stairs
five in the morning
this coming from this radio i hear
crying too am i supposed to see what
that is
i have no idea oh i hate it i hate it
so much i hate that god i hate that
i hate this oh hate
oh god
i hate it all right i'm just gonna go
because i gotta i gotta get downstairs
before gym
whatever okay i don't know why that was
a thing but it's not my concern at the
moment because
why
someone at the door is someone at the
front door
dare i answer the front door excuse me
my nipple itches
hello hi hey what's up oh
god who's knock knock knockin
hello oh
i don't remember oh god where's the
where where
where maybe i'm oh
god no
oh no what is here
where
okay clearly there's nothing here um
probably should follow
my compass but you know i'm kind of dumb
condom not that one for sure
someone in here no oh god
oh god
[Music]
well dr bose you got some answering to
do
hello is it doctor bose mr bose
yes you're dr bose
well you will seem to be in a bit of a
kerfuffle
[Music]
i decided to take control once and for
all wait
wait okay wait hold on a second wait
um what
take control once wait i don't think i
have an item related to uh take control
once and for all in here you know i'm
you know i'm kind of looking through my
various little things here you know
take control once and for all isn't
exactly something that's popping up here
so um i'm gonna go to the third floor
and come back to this later
why why'd you go
don't go blah blah i know that i
probably need to ask him something but
i don't exactly know what that is yet
and i still have to go to the third
floor to talk about that other dude
the husband or something or the
boyfriend i can't remember
exactly but uh someone was banging on
the third floor and i gotta go
see what's up with that a noise
complaint
apparently i'm the management at this
place no one else is gonna keep it
together what happened to my friends are
they still there
why aren't they screaming if i was
kidnapped i would be screaming a lot
more
i'd be screaming like real good big
screams all the time even if i was
muffled that big scream energy
okay all right
do i hear a jimmy swunking around
no i hear a knocking so some kind of a
knocking
happening here-ish this way-ish
okay hi hello
how are you looking around
searching okay i already got that ring
why is it still there
i guess i didn't take it whatever i
already have a compass
okay so i've already been in here maybe
that's what i need to ask him about
did he have an answer for the ring i
don't know i don't know
so the thing pointed me into this room
but why
all right let's consult the skry let's
cry
good old jimster jiminy jimbo
the doc we love the doc
what or do we what happens when he takes
control once and for
two two three two two three
two two three okay two to three we need
to go to two to three
two to three remember that very closely
write it in the comments two to three
we need to get to two to three okay and
then we need to look out the window or
the other one on the third floor i think
i think that's third floor looky-loo
but i'm aren't i at the third floor
lookie-loo
[Music]
wasn't i in the third floor looking
isn't that where i am right now
anyway to the tree so i oops no that's
not what i was hoping for
maybe it's what i needed to do i don't
know but i'm
pretty sure that what i'm gonna need to
do is
to the tree yeah i was pretty sure that
was exactly what that
lookie-loo was but i'm not seeing any
looky-loo
jimmy please do not get me
no no no no
no no no
jimmy dear jimmy
you are such a
lovely person with a great
personality and a lovely
smile are you going to kill me are you
going to kill me
am i about to die i don't think so
so what was it well i'm still in danger
it says
it says i'm still in date what is it
oh
[Music]
what is happening is it coming here is
it gonna get me what is happening
[Music]
am i okay
it's still why why why why why
i'm gonna look i'm looking big look
what what what the hell just happened
whoa
what just happened
what the hell just happened
well that's not right that
wha what the hell is happening
what the hell
i know you can hear me i know you made
it up your little story about that
psychiatrist
i know where you got it from i knew i've
read it before isn't your bloody
scrapbook
come out here jimmy
well i have no idea what's going on
but i'm free as a bird now gonna save
cause that was weird um okay
well i found some
all right he's not actually out there is
he i'm not
actually about to die
well you man you
well i don't hear him step stepping but
yeah i honestly i don't know if i can
trust my ears at the moment
i'm gonna go well actually no wait i'm
gonna turn on this
is there anyone there is a harvey are
you there
okay so you're are you outside this door
do i have to step outside
i think i do i think i do god damn it
okay
fine let's just let's here we go
is it javi harvey
hello oh too distant still oh really
where do i gotta like look this way or
something
here is it javi is it
harvey
[Music]
no you can to turn whatever to their
shirt what do you mean to derson
what are you talking about too durston
here
okay apparently here is it harvey harvey
the harvester okay
now we're in business okay i saw you
shouting through the door
telling jimmy to admit he lied this all
ties in it's all ties together
interesting okay so little traps
would that have anything to do with like
what was going on
[Music]
sitting on a bed talking to jimmy what
was he doing
don't know okay that's fine that's fine
i saw dr both trying to explain what
happened with jimmy
he seemed desperate
he was worried about what else jimmy
would make up about and he was right
um okay these aren't big discoveries
i need to pair this with something but i
i gotta go scry
what are you doing don't do the piano
blues i don't want the panel blue
no not in the bathroom get out of the
bathroom you coward get out of there
i ain't no coward i ain't no i'm
an
investigative reporter or actually i
think i'm just a student but
for now gonna use my big brain to solve
the mystery of the whole
hotel
all right dr mose are you a bastard did
you manage to take control of everything
because if you did
i want to know exactly what you do
that's right the two two three we gotta
go the two two three
and then we gotta talk to this guy about
something
something special all right
uh what am i looking at what is that
like a
the radiate the radiator the radiator
i forgot about the faulty radiator i
forgot about that
okay the faulty radiator that's that's
definitely something to consider so if i
talk to dr
bose about the faulty radiator
yes harvey okay dangerous heater
uh ma'am when you said jimmy started
setting traps for you
yeah yeah did you have anything to do
with what you said about the dangerous
heater right yeah
jimmy was always playing with
was never the electricity who got
shocked yeah well he probably did a few
times explain the hair or oh
i feel like that would be a little bit
more than just you know
harmless prank i feel like that would be
dead detonating
the dead dead dead destinating
okay 44 three we're making good progress
okay jimmy
you better not be there that's all i
gotta say you better not be there
okay good i'm getting out of here i'm
out of here i'm out of here i'll
screw you
okay i do have to go the two two three
but
let me actually you know i'll work my
way down yeah let's go to the tip three
you'll never catch me not like
there are stairs
all right there is a bit of a
problem because
i have a funny feeling if if if like my
keys don't if i can't seem to access my
keys which i
can't seem to do i wonder i'm kind of
curious as to
how i'm going to open up certain doors
that might only be locked by behind a
key
uh where are we 22219 okay
no no no god god no god lord god no
leave okay we gotta find the two two
three that was not the two two three
okay praise be the
two two three dude no
the two two ah of course
of course okay so who's in here
who the hell key
nothing's happening i've got storeroom
key
i found garrote wire
that's a little weird key
two two three dead lucky apparently i
have to go find those again
is that gonna show up this time oh god
it is god damn it okay
well at least i have the key to the
storeroom so that is good
i also have this
hi jimmy and gymster
what is my dude what is up
i'm just gonna scry that seems like the
best option just to make sure i
absolutely do not get lost
i get some evidence i scry my future
i look into the ether i stare into the
beyond and it stares back into my soul
and then i encapsulate everything that i
need to do
right now
oh god
he was very strangly i did get a lot of
strangle energy from him
i got like a lot of strange ability
he seemed to have strong strangle
fingers
dr bose they didn't say he was a
licensed
masseuse and he must sooshed his fingers
around your neck
and massaged yeah not the best
not the best not the best for the
recipient
of the massage the message
not the massager okay so i i'm in
trouble because i am in a dead end
but i think it's okay seems like he's
gone
and he didn't hear that definitely
okay seems okay
okay i heard that
okay first straight shot okay
okay so
i'm just gonna first i'm just gonna go
down to g because i've got the
this triangle wire i've got the
strangulator
rolling pin strangulation clothesline
business
i'm going to see how dr bose took this
into his strong
capable hands his incredible
masculine hands
his strangulators
dr bose all right he's not here
is someone there hello i need a haircut
hello hello um how what do you think
about
strangling you know just what's your
opinion
about strangulation dr bose didn't have
an answer what do you mean it didn't
have an answer
this is his strangulator
this is the strangletron 2000.
why didn't he it didn't even give him an
amy didn't amy
is it dr bose dr bose wait what the hell
is happening
okay oh it just didn't take okay why was
there a washing line tied around a
rolling pin
is this good for strangling in
[Music]
he's a doctor he experiments he
experiments
okay uh so when you said you were gonna
take control when you said you decided
to take control once and for all
does that have anything to do with what
you said about the washing line and
rolling pin
i experimented with the washing but it
was tuesday
[Music]
oh oh oh
oh oh no wait no
oh no oh oh oh oh oh
oh no
oh oh oh no
oh no oh
um alrighty then
i think i know why the other lift is
out of order i think i know that now
um i think i might
know uh
[Music]
oh
hello
[Music]
what a terrible waiter oh my god
that would pop your head off like a
water strawberry
it would explode your head off god
damn your neck bones are never going to
be able to fight an elevator
hey dr bose you there hey dr bones
hey bonnie hey buzzy boy
hey what's up too distant okay too
distant ah i got you okay hey
hey doctor bones did your head pop off
yes like all right
right
but the whole elevator being involved
that's just a
that's another level let's take well
taking it to another level in the
elevator sorry
is it too soon oh here's the show is
starting i get to go to the theater
i need to go to the theater
hey there you go dr mo's story over
great well so far
all i'm getting is jimmy is innocent
innocent
innocent he has yet to hurt a fly
he's yet to actually kill anybody he's
totally not guilty
nope no sorry
just uh just uh you know
rap scalia's youth you know rap scalia
says some might say
me i would say that rap scalias
rap scalius oh can i go
why would i want to why would i want to
oof hate oh no i don't want to see the
show
i don't want to behold
i am the great hugo
why does that guy sound like me
[Music]
what the hell but he did sound like me
right
behold i am the great
hugo i mean it
kind of sounded like me to be perfect on
it i did not do it i know the great hugo
on stage hey
hey hey hugo hey hooxster i think
hookster is jimmy but you know i just go
call out to jimmy should i
should i do that hey
hey uh he never he's never on the ground
floor
kind of a kind of a big baby you know
he's kind of a big baby
some some have noted some have called
them a big baby before some have said
that actually he's kind of a big baby
you know i'm not pointing i'm not
pointing fingers you know but
some may have said he's kind of a big
baby
where's this where the hell is this
compass pointing what is it doing it's
not doing anything
what what are you doing you're you're
pointing at
nothing all right whatever
i guess i i think it's just i think
there's nothing here i think it's just
spinning aimlessly so i gotta go to
another floor or i gotta cry
let me go scry in the kitchen for a
little bit
get an idea of what i do next hello
i saw the great hugo
he was great and
probably drugged me during the show
which just means
great show excellent show
fantastic all right number one okay so
now we're just on to harvey i don't know
what the great hugo was all about
but you know the hoogster can really uh
really entertain a crowd you know maybe
maybe i should have just gone and seen
the show
you know in all honesty this probably
never would have happened
none of this if i had just gone to see
an old hugel's show
you know it's my fault it's really my
fault
i'm the one to blame hope i'm not
popping dr moses head straight
a point gone well that's a shame that's
why there's two thumps
hate it i hate it i hate it okay i think
this is pointing this way
oh god wait did i hear what i think i
heard
oh oh god okay here yeah
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
well guess i'll go in 113.
oh it's so dark
it's fine hey harv
is it javi is it harvey
yeah yeah
all right harvey hey what's up with this
electric shock
what happened
he knew that was my heater he had the
casing straight to the mains
almost
[Music]
he damaged my property so i decided to
damage his
it's only fair it's only fair what about
the hugo someone
[Music]
you never knew the great hugo i was
talking about
tying a rope around his neck he killed
himself did his hand explode off
[Music]
everyone thought
you see too clever
the plot thickens the plot thickens
because you know there's always a
possibility what if jimmy wasn't
necessarily lying what if this doctor
actually wasn't just
you know yeah not that i want to give
jimmy the benefit of the doubt here but
you know
we i don't know the whole story that's
why i'm trying to figure it out
all right anyway uh so what about you
don't remember the broken mirrors okay
so it definitely wasn't that
it probably wasn't the copper wire
because how could you really break that
trophies didn't have an answer for that
so it definitely wasn't that
well what else is there's not really
things here
i mean could be the scrapbook but
whatever it's it's not quite the same
i mean it could be wait maybe it could
be
i guess uh this seems it seems weird
does that have something to do with what
you said about the scrapbook
yeah i didn't think so that was a pretty
weak connection okay let me just go out
and let me scry so i can
at least get an idea of what to do next
yeah i better do just cry and that way i
don't have to try to guess
a million times waste more time doing
that
[Music]
come on come on come on come on hurry up
hurry up how long does it take to get a
message through the fourth dimension
come on ah 203
interesting see i would never would have
guessed that how would i ever have been
able to figure that out
anyway okay jimmy are you there you
better not be there you
bastard you better not be there you
bastard you
bastard you bastard you rat bastard you
rat bastard don't you dare
i hear something but i think he's really
far away it might also be that radio
but then again that's a problem because
[Music]
funny about that i don't think you do
i really don't think you do jimmy i
think you are
sadly mistaken
okay that's what i thought dick bag
douche nozzle idiot fool
uh nave
i don't i don't know any more insults
whatever
he sounds pretty close so i'm gonna let
him give i'm gonna give him a chance to
pass on by before i do anything for him
because i think the swelling of the
music is definitely an indication that
he is nearby and that i should be
concerned for my life and safety
before i see anything about going
outside
was x to
that was definitely a thumpy
what was yeah what was the key uh
dips dip yeah d
okay i'm not hearing anything
is that a footstep okay i think it's
okay
let's try to go let's try for it let's
go for it
okay okay
okay oh
my god oh geez okay not there that's not
good
that's not good at all
hmm
i guess we're fine this is still reading
yeah that's that's concerning
music is definitely swelling up a little
bit oh
i don't know if he like waits
in the spot
hey i'm not exactly sure how his
behavior works
in terms of like where he waits and
lurks
he's good at lurking dr bo is good at
strangling
him good at lurking he's great at that
okay so far so far hey okay we're clear
okay i think we're good
i'm gonna try i'm gonna try this
let me try this go for it here we go
let's make it happen maybe not
maybe not maybe not make it happen maybe
don't make it happen don't make that
happen
i should never have made that happen
well he's a bit of a prick
great at lurking though oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh my god oh my god
i'm gonna die
i'm a dead man i'm a dead man
i'm a dead man oh hey
hugo are you the great
[Music]
hugo
i'm dead i'm dead i'm dead i'm so dead
he's gonna come in he's gonna get me
he's gonna get me he's gonna get me he's
gonna get me
he's gonna get me ah damn it he got me
oh
really painful gosh my head my
nog really you really
want me on my no i'm skipping this oh
gosh skip this you suck
dick bag you douche you know what at
least you just
wonkas me you know at least you just
want
203 isn't that the room that i needed
[Music]
he was just giving me a shortcut
he was just giving me a shorty cut
i went the wrong way probably the oh god
i went the wrong way where where the
hell
did i just go but he just gave me a
shorty cut
although i do need to go get the the
thingamabob oh god i'm going i literally
went the complete wrong way
okay so yeah if i had just gone yeah i
was literally right there okay
so i'm gonna quickly go down get my
radio this
dick bag is gonna get out of my way i'm
gonna get what i need to get
two or three i thought it was 203 it
might not be 203
but whatever i'm gonna get it and i'm
gonna get going i'm gonna get my thing
i'm gonna get out of here and screw you
jimmy hugo
you're not nearly as cool as the hugster
let me tell you that let me tell you
that straight up
let me tell you i don't know if i could
turn that off now
yeah yeah yeah i'm pretty sure it was
actually 203
oddly enough thank you yes i know what
it looks like
all right let's go either way i think it
was on the second floor because my
compass was doing it
doing a dance anyway
very dramatic yeah
[Music]
all right maybe it'd be better to hide
in the closet or something
i don't know i don't know if either of
them are going to be better because the
bathroom definitely doesn't seem to be
the trick maybe it's like a 50 50 shot
when it's
like when he's in the room like that who
knows
who knows who knows okay i'm pretty sure
it was 203 maybe
down here
no no no wait no it's just spinning
aimlessly
am i not on the right floor was it one
did i need to be on one
i can't remember i think maybe one
now my brain ain't working too good so
i'm um
not a hundred percent sure
but if i am wrong i'll just scry up
behind the first door that i see
gymster jimbo were you down here
were you down here
okay yeah so there's definitely
something here
[Music]
i could just find that there was
something on two though but maybe not
maybe i'm just being stupid because i'm
definitely being pointed this way
no no no no no no no
no no no wait no but oh this is the room
that i was just in
there's nothing else to get here is
there i already got the electrical shock
i didn't need to talk to him anymore did
i did he
i thought he said two or three didn't it
say two other am i dumb god did i just
go in a big circle because i needed to
go two or three and i didn't actually go
in the room and if i just went in the
room i would have
i know two two three ah
god it was i it was
oh it was if i had just walked in the
room i would have been fine
freak
frick frick
oh god do not give me again
oh god
i'm just going i'm just going i'm just
going i'm just going i'm just going
i'm just going yeah i think it was the
radio but i'm just going
[Music]
to ah yeah screw you i knew he was right
behind me i knew i knew
i somehow knew i knew but he's too slow
okay this time i'm just gonna go to 203
god damn it
god damn it 203 real quick like
lickety split here we go he's really
confused you know he's just like
what the hell is this person doing maybe
i hit him too many times with the batter
they
they seem to not be doing so good
yeah gotta not hit me so good
you're hitting me whoa
damn nice bro nice nice sick
what do i do with those oh yeah
do i go back now do i go back is that
what i do
man i really went loop-de-loo for this
really didn't
look dulu what i was supposed to do but
you know how it goes
hey yeah i'm confused too
okay bat okay batus
okay that's definitely what uh
definitely what jimmy uses
i'm guessing i just go see him again i
should have just gone i didn't even need
to scry i i knew it was up i know how
this game goes
i didn't check
we're good we're good bro we're good
i think we're fine we're so good
did i go the wrong way where the f did i
go i did oh my god i did
holy god damn it
oh i'm so dumb
before i'm going for it go screw me
screw me screw you screw me ah getting
out of here
look along clunk clunk
we're good guys we're good don't you
worry about a thing let me worry about
things
i'm good at worrying i'm good at
worrying just let me worry about things
and everything's gonna be
a-okay 113 and
i think actually this way is the faster
way to 113.
113 yes it was the faster way to 113.
all right harvster the harvinator
no not yet not yet here look in the
darkness and then ask a question
yeah good good what do you think about
this
what was all that about hmm what was all
that about weird
need
when you said you decided to damage this
property does that have something to do
with what you said about the cricket and
baseball bat
wonka lung did you wonk wonka lunk wonka
lunka chunkawonky's
[Music]
okay so i need to go to room two all
right
i'm gonna i'm gonna end this episode
here but we're halfway through the game
and now we're making considerable
progress
so it shouldn't be much longer before
i've got this
under wrapped so thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know what you
thought down in the comments below
did you remember all the important
information i told you to memorize
because the next episode there's going
to be a quiz
so you better study up and look for the
secret code that was definitely in this
video somewhere definitely don't laugh
it's not a joke maybe
anyway thank you better watch again just
in case you never know
something anyway thank you and as always
i will see you
in the next video bye-bye
you